you head by the teacher yeah
i don't know if you've seen the [ __ ]
uh breakfast club [ __ ]
that was the headline morehead teacher
so you headbutted i didn't i didn't he
was an intervention specialist so they
hit you for with
aggravated assault yeah and what they do
is they
the job they have is to grab the kids
slam them and let them know who the boss
and i felt like he was trying to be do
too much i'm older now i understand bro
you
you're doing your job so i appreciate
you but at the time i was a knucklehead
and i didn't
i didn't like that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
my face what were you doing that where
they had to
intervene no cat i wasn't doing [ __ ]
like i was trying to write my girl a
little lovely that i got doing my work
on time so i'm gonna computer [ __ ]
right hello let it
he was like did you actually use the
computer i'm like yo bro i already got
it okay with the teacher like you're not
gonna teach my [ __ ] relax let's go in
the hallway where your job is
and i'm in my business he i printed out
get ready to fold it up i write draw him
her name on it my hearts
he take my [ __ ] rip it and throw it in
the trash he like i said you had a
permission dude i'm like yo bro chill
the [ __ ] out just ask this [ __ ] if i
could do it he said yeah
you know how i am chill out bro i'm
trying to have a good [ __ ] day ma i'm
already got mashing on my brain
i'm dealing with real [ __ ] life in
this school get the [ __ ] out of my face
you feel me like
and i don't think he understood where i
was coming from like i'm a kid you was
doing a lot
of [ __ ] at home at the time a lot of
[ __ ] at home a lot of [ __ ] in the street
last year with my family last year with
myself it's like bro get the [ __ ] out of
here like i'm really i'm in this school
for a reason because i'm i'm trying to
get out of the [ __ ] you feel me
[ __ ] didn't understand it i wrote it
again he grabbed the paper again and
ripped it i'm like yo bro i'm about to
steal you like you really pissing me off
he went in my face with the grab me
first thing i [ __ ] it
let me there
like five [ __ ] on me so was it
sophomore year yeah 10th grade yep hell
yeah
i was on the ground like 20 minutes
later police came i was behind in the
cop car and
was down yeah yeah but probably all that
[ __ ] buddy so you end up in jail
juvie's uh juvie yeah obviously um
damn so you got your gd in juventus yeah
my dumb ass thought i could get my ged
and go back to high school i don't know
why i thought that [ __ ]
i got okay i was like bro you already
graduated yeah i was like yeah it's over
now that's my gd
show today i'm doing well so i can get
out then go to high school play football
and get my
i got out like what the [ __ ]
i'm 16 i'm out of school i don't know
what the [ __ ] to do with my life
what were you doing like you get out of
jail 16 done with high school all your
friends are probably still in school
you've been gone a year and a half like
what did you end up doing with your free
time
uh that that's when the time god gotta
get a little shifty you feel me like
when you start chilling with [ __ ]
who's not in school now you start
chilling with them [ __ ] you have to
chill because nobody's around but older
[ __ ]
they start trying to be involved and
follow really deep into their ways
because that's all you know now
all my homies that i would probably
chill with and if we fight and we do
dumb [ __ ] that's cool we be kids
right but the older [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
around like that like you feel me
you get into some real [ __ ] and like
thank y'all [ __ ] for the lessons but i
[ __ ] wish i never learned them
lessons so you was around some like
that's like you kind of got out of jail
and then the circle you started to keep
was
definitely not the same circle that you
would before you would win because all
your friends are probably going to
school
yeah [ __ ] just football doing doing
they think so like but
i've always tried to keep a uh another
circle if you mean like
every hood [ __ ] if you really in the
street like that you got to have some
[ __ ] who not
so when you explain your [ __ ] out loud
to these [ __ ] who don't understand it
it sounds dumb as [ __ ]
yo this [ __ ] said these [ __ ] talking
chris i'm about to pull up and dinner
you know the guy he beeping with nah so
why you gotta go do it because he said
so
oh damn now you're like what the [ __ ]
hell no what the [ __ ] you need you need
homies to be like yo that i don't that
[ __ ] don't make sense to me you mean i
think
i always kept those so when i finally
went back to favor and i had to
understand who i was and find myself i
have my kid i'm like yo i
i don't want to be that following ass
[ __ ] who really got to sit back and
like that decision was
dumb as [ __ ] cause i followed another
[ __ ]